bonsoir jérôme marty merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
9000 cas près de 9000 cas positifs
dépister ce soir le virus circule à
l'évidence comment interprétez vous ce
chiffre est ce qu'il faut s'en inquiéter
selon vous elle verrait circuit et puis
avec le nombre de cas augmente on le
voit et deux jours un jour l'été sur un
record qui était de 7000 hommes passent
maintenant neuf pilonné sur une une base
virale qui montent régulièrement et puis
surtout cela fait trois jours qu'on a
une augmentation de cas en réanimation
et une augmentation de cas en
hospitalisation alors qu'on était plutôt
sur un régime d'oscillations jusqu'à
présent avec des montées puis la
descente
là ça monte depuis trois jours on va
voir si les jours prochaine confirme
notre confirme la tendance mais très
visiblement on a une augmentation de 2
de la diffusion de l'épidémie
fort heureusement on n'est pas dans un
état comparable à celui du mois de mars
ou du mois d'avril et c'est ce qu'il
faut bien voir puisque aujourd'hui les
mesures barrières ont été mises en place
on a mis des masques obligatoire en
entreprise
on a mis des masques obligatoire dans
les écoles on dispose d'aucune
protection dans le secteur sanitaire
dans les techniques dans les hôpitaux
à partir de là on voit qu'on peut lutter
conte traditionnel cette épidémie avec
un peu d'avancé alors qu'au mois de mars
et en avril on habite en permanence
quinze jours trois semaines de retard ce
qui nous a amenés à des drames à une
diffusion beaucoup plus importante
alors il ya aussi ces chiffres en europe
l'italie notamment qui déclare dix fois
moins de cas que la france à peu près
ces cas également de la grande bretagne
est ce que ça veut dire que ces pays des
pistes - ou qu'ils protègent mieux leurs
populations contre la circulation du
virus
c'est difficile c'est difficile à
comprendre
on a peut-être eu des mesures qui ont
été mises en place plus tôt notamment le
port du masque en lieu clos ça c'est
tout à fait possible maintenant on n'a
pas toutes et tous les éléments qu'on
vous le savez par rapport à 7 par
rapport à cette pathologie il des pistes
aussi peut-être moins bien que l'on voit
bien que l'augmentation des cas positifs
dans notre dans notre pays est plus
rapide que l'augmentation du nombre de
tests donc s'attendre à vouloir dire que
il y à bien une diffusion de l'épidémie
est ce que ce ne sont pas que la cause
n'est pas juste l'augmentation des tests
oui il ya bien la circulation du virus
le vrai chiffre finalement qui a d'art à
bien appréhender cette ce virus c'est ce
sont le nombre de cas en réanimation
aujourd'hui qui sont hospitalisés
aujourd'hui pour vous non le vrai chic
froid que l'erreur ça serait de regarder
cette maladie sous le prisme uniquement
de la réanimation et d'hospitalisation
ça et ça a été l'erreur véritablement
qu'on a fait au mois de mars au mois
d'avril vous savez à cette époque
malades n'existait que lorsqu ils
trahissaient les murs de l'hôpital
on n'a pas considéré la médecine de
ville et on a perdu du temps là je crois
qu'il faut bien regarder ce que fait la
médecine de ville
nous on alerte au blizzard attention à
chaque jour de plus en plus de patients
qui présentent des symptômes on les
teste pour l'art et plus en plus de
patients qui nous disent qu'ils ont été
en contact avec des cas positifs ce qui
montre que la maladie diffuse maintenant
nous n'avons pas de passage ou peu de
passage entre le groupe qui est les
jeunes les groupes à forte interaction
sociale qui fort heureusement fait peu
de symptômes ou est asymptomatique et le
groupe à risque que sont les personnes
âgées mais plus on va avoir deux cas
chez les personnes jeunes plus on a un
risque que cela diffuse vers les
personnes âgées un peu comme dans une
inondation quand vous essayer d'arrêter
l'eau à venir au bout d'un certain
niveau ça finit par passer
donc là on a une traîne c'est que cela
finisse par passer on aura des
hospitalisations alors à des
réanimations certainement un moins grand
nombre que lors de la première phase
mais en bonne voie quand on parle de
près de 9000 contamination des pistes et
aujourd'hui il peut se fier d'avoir plus
un conte est il finalement d'une dune
d'un élément de comparaison avant le
confinement et il y en avait autant
voire plus faire avant le second
finalement je crois que ce qu'on a
oublié c'est que début mars par exemple
si on se replace au tour du cap au 5
mars
on avait à peine 2 3 à trois décès sur
le territoire qu'on était vraiment un
coup début et qu'après on l'a eu
l'accélération qui a été très rapide
mais encore une fois je le répète on
n'avait pas de masse pour le sait on l'a
assez répété on ne testait pas on
n'avait pas d'ailleurs de moyenne de
tester donc on était très en retard
aujourd'hui on est on est beaucoup plus
en avance on a mis en oeuvre les choses
donc on peut légitimement penser qu'on
saura réagir maintenant la problématique
à la côte est on met trop de temps pour
tester
on voit bien qu'il ya des files
d'attentes l'ours
malade va se faire tester il faut des
fois deux jours pour qu'il arrive à se
faire tester ensuite deux jours pour
avoir le diagnostic et quand il s'est
présenté à son medecin il avait déjà des
symptômes depuis trois jours et on sait
qu'il est vecteur du virus déjà deux
jours avant d'avoir des symptômes
souvent il s'est passé neuf jours entre
le moment où il a commencé avec morizet
du virus et le moment où il a le
résultat du test et là on va le on va le
le l'isoler pendant 14 jours alors même
qu'il ne sécrète plus de virus puisqu un
secteur du virus elles deux jours avant
les symptômes et les 7 jours suivant
donc on est trop tardif il faut que nos
cibles sur les lieux à risque et
conteste beaucoup plus dans les lieux à
risque tout contester toute la
population et les lieux à risques
précisément corrigez moi si je me trompe
son gain bien évidemment ces lieux qui
sont clos qui ne sont pas erré un
pathogène qui serait d'ailleurs
hautement transmissible par l'air
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit c'est pas
simplement des gouttelettes qui sont
projetés c'est aussi l'air qui
véhiculent ce virus c'est ça fait partie
des choses que la médecine de ville le
disait depuis depuis assez longtemps
mais il y a une aéropôle isation de ce
virus effectivement un centre précis pas
le mode de transmission c'est par l'air
et donc si les lieux clos puisque il y a
qu institution de ce fameux général
qu'il faut s'imaginer format nuage de
fumée comme à l'époque un total de ce
tabagisme passif
parce qu'il ya les signatures et que
tout le monde respire et mais ce nuage
virale c'est la même chose et donc on ne
comprend aisément que c'est un lieu clos
qu'il se situe puisque à l'extérieur il
est dit il et il était diluée et s'en va
très vite puisqu'il n'y a pas de plafond
et le vent le tribut donc il n'y a pas
cette problématique à l'extérieur
la contamination de masse se fait à
l'intérieur il ya également peu de
pertes moines personnes en tout cas en
réanimation
une des raisons c'est qu'on en tubes
plus systématiquement les malades donc
on les q - également à cause de cette
pratique dont je crois que ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'on a ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est qu'on a appris de cette maladie
kamel on sait mieux agir dessus
voilà des traitements la base de portico
thérapie on a des traitements à base
d'anticoagulants qui font que l'on évite
des effets secondaires graves de cette
maladie notamment les embolies
pulmonaires et donc on a moins
d'incarnation des patients et on a moins
de 2,2
de nécessité de lezennes tubes et de les
coucher sur le ventre comme on le
faisait maintenant on est encore une
fois au début il faut espérer qu'on
n'ira pas plus loin alors un mot à mot
de ces polémiques contre le professeur
didier raoult vous qu'il est fondé
d'ailleurs une médecine livre que pensez
vous de cette plainte déposée par par
vos confrères contre le professeur
didier raoult août at il oui ou non
enfreint le code de déontologie selon
vous n'at-il pas n'at-il pas eu le droit
de prescrire ce qui lui semble bon alors
que personne ne savait quoi faire
au début de l'épidémie si l'on se place
sur le plan légal c'est l'essai de la
réalité le problème c'est
qu'effectivement il a en frêne des
articles du code de déontologie
mais surtout il n'a pas donné les moyens
à la médecine de ville véritablement
d'expliquer aux patients si ce
traitement fonctionne au s'ils ne
fonctionnent pas moi je n'ai jamais
dérogé de la même ligne à chaque fois
j'ai toujours dit la problématique c'est
que si on avait eu des études
véritablement construite sur une base
académique en double aveugle et cetera
on aurait pu dire si ça marche ça marche
pas elle n'a pas été le cas et en face
de lui
on n'a pas voulu mettre en place des
études qui prenait les bases de son
protocole et donc nous les médecins nous
sommes retrouvés les médecins de ville
entre le faire et l'enclume dans
l'incapacité de dire à nos patients
si ça marche aussi ça marche pas et ça
c'est très embêtant et puis maintenant
on a eu une montée de violence extrême
entre les pro et les anti
comme s'il s'agissait presque de d'un
mouvement qui était comment dire si sur
un homme puisque sur la science est là
il faut un peu que tout le monde
retrouve son calme
on est tous des hommes de science on se
doit de devoir expliquer les choses
sainement posément et elle n'était pas
le cas jusqu'à présent
alors si on comparait effectivement même
moment alors que le professeur out
préconisé son protocole le gouvernement
lui disait de ne pas porter de masque
les médecins de ville disait quoi leurs
patients à ce moment là les médecins de
ville disait que leur manquer le tout
commenté de masques commenté le test
qu'il qui ne file ne pouvait pas qu'ils
ne pouvaient pas arrêter la diffusion de
cette épidémie parce qu'il n'avait pas
de moyen de les protéger
on était extrêmement embêter
souvenez-vous à l'époque quand on a
vingt patients qui étaient porteurs de
la maladie on le renvoyer chez lui on ne
pouvait pas même pas prescrire de
masques pour éviter que cette maladie
diffusons scène
voyez familiale et on avait donc des
contaminations entre familiale dont paul
été embêté sur le plan autant
structurelles que sur le plan des moyens
de souhaits oui donc finalement c'est
les mesures qu on préconisait à l'époque
était tout aussi nocives en tout cas si
tenté que celle du professeur out le
soin pour pour les malades puisqu'elle
contaminés au sein de leur foyer visite
des personnes n'arrivent les mesures y
en avait partout
la problématique c'est que des mesures à
l'époque je n'avais pas puisque encore
une fois le seul la seule mesure folle a
été capable d'avoir c'était le pôle
finement total et global parce qu'on
manquait de moyens de protection parce
qu'on n'avait pas voulu dire aux manqué
deux bouts de deux masques et donc on
s'est retrouvé dans l'incapacité à la
fois de pouvoir protéger les soignants
est dans l'incapacité de pouvoir
protéger la population il ne restait
donc une solution qu'était l'isolément
le confinement
alors que si on avait eu comme de
notamment comme dans les pays asiatiques
à disposition des tests en nombre et à
disposition des masques en nombre on
aurait pu on le voit très bien protéger
la population et surtout ne pas bloquer
l'économie dans le même temps est-ce que
ce qui manque selon vos professeurs
martys sont aussi c'est peut-être aussi
un peu plus de discipline de la part des
personnes puisqu'on sait que les
contaminations se font souvent dans des
lieux privés à huis clos
non je crois que ça c'est l'exception
vous savez on heureux ne voit que la
partie émergée de l'iceberg toute la
partie qui se passe bien on la voit pas
on ne parle pas des trains qui arrivent
à l'heure la majorité l'immense majorité
la population a parfaitement intégré
comment se protéger de cette pathologie
comment on l'évité qu'elle diffuse et
dans les entreprises autant que dans les
dalles et dans les grands magasins dans
les transports en commun on revient que
les moyens sont utilisés que les moyens
de protection sont divisés et c'est pour
ça c'est ce qui c'est une des
explications au fait que la maladie
diffuse peu chez les gens à risque
actuellement
merci mr salué le comportement de la
population française
merci beaucoup géré marty pour votre
intervention ce soir je rappelle que
vous êtes un médecin et président du
syndicat de l'union française pour une
médecine ni brin merci de votre
participation